Karaoke is helping to heal the wounds of last year's tsunami.
Traditional folk songs are the favorites among the residents of Ofunato's temporary housing.
It is good fun, it heals the heart.
Gathering together in a group and singing and talking to each other is great.
This musical get together is taking place on board a purpose built truck currently touring Japan's tsunami hit coast,...
...bringing counseling and karaoke to the bereaved communities.
Yoshinobu Konno is from the charity 'Friends of the United Nations,' which came up with the idea.
People who live in these small prefabricated houses lost their families and their homes and are often depressed.
So, they are often alone.
They do not want to make contact with other people, they become introspective.
One thing we are concerned about is that people could die here alone in their houses.
So, that is why we are intervening now to try to prevent mental illnesses from taking hold.
This housing block is one of dozens erected in Japan in the months following the tsunami.
Visiting salesmen bring life's essentials and the odd luxury.
In the small cove below, there is nothing left of the residents' original homes.
Demolition teams have flattened the few structures that the tsunami left behind.
Ofunato was one of the worst hit towns when the tsunami roared ashore nearly a year ago.
The bays and headlands of this coastline once famed for its beauty were decimated.
Further south, a freighter still looms over Kesennuma town, carried several kilometers inland by the tsunami.
It is impossible to forget the horrors of a year ago, but the town is trying to move on.
A mini village has sprung up to rehouse businesses washed away.
Chefs and shopkeepers offer a taste of Kesennuma's once famed seafood.
Among them, Masayoshi Hatakeyama.
His traditional Japanese inn was entirely destroyed.
His new workplace may be cramped, but he says it is a first step on a very long road.
The tsunami destroyed a huge area so it would take a long time and hard work to get back to how it was before.
I guess it will not be like it was before.
We will have to create a new town.
Under the direction of a newly formed Ministry of Reconstruction, this wrecked coastline is being transformed with astonishing speed.
Back in Ofunato, survivors say it will take much longer to rebuild their communities.
Many question whether anyone will want to live here at all.
Henry Ridgwell, VOA News, Ofunato, Japan.